did you meet trump when you roasted him  yes this is actually one of my favorite  stories ever because that guy is first  and foremost an entertainer um did the  roast i'm hammering him and there was an  off-limits thing every roast has an  off-limits trump it was melania and i  just was like i'm not cutting i mean i  had like four pages of [ __ ] melania  jokes about that and then oh the diamond  you shouldn't have gotten uh melania is  such a big diamond ring now she knows  what heart is supposed to feel like  like we're talking making fun of his  hair we're making fun of his like how  bad he is at business like naming and he  was like dying laughing the whole time  get off stage and he pulls me close puts  his hand on my lower back he goes that  was great television wow  television he gets  any other interaction with him um not  really he did ask for my number though  but he didn't call me that now do you  feel a sense of rejection that he didn't  reach out yeah my  easy to grab